[Music]
after 17 movies the MCU finally went
black putting out a black crude black
cat superhero movie that's one of the
best ever released leaving its haters
with only one option watching every
other MCU movie ever made hmm black
panther just when you thought chadwick
boseman had called dibs on every black
icon he's suiting up as black panther a
superhero with a high-tech suit of iron
man the all-natural steroids of Captain
America and the invisible jet of Wonder
Woman but one thing sets him apart from
all the other MCU heroes not cuz he's
black
not cuz he's royalty nope it's cuz this
Marvel hero just won't quit shooting at
me let me put on my helmet enough in
cross we will not help you
did he freeze I can internal him
headlights are you finished well his dad
just died and he didn't even crack a
joke I thought you had to be a smartass
to save the world
dance off frog journey to Wakanda a
combination of the Jetsons and a 1990s
Jet magazine it's the source of all the
world's vibranium a material so powerful
it tops Tony Stark's tech and dr.
Strange's magic as the BS that can do
whatever the script needs it to do
because vibranium on those trains its
library neom all around us that's how I
hated you
this secret kingdom has been hidden for
centuries thanks to an ironclad policy
of asking people not to say anything but
after sitting out the slave trade brutal
dictators two world wars multiple alien
invasions and a sentient AI using stolen
vibranium to destroy the earth they're
finally ready to get involved in Bay
Area real estate I bought this building
well that's a pity
kitten steps you guys after taking 18
movies to get six quality villains cry
as Marvel takes just three movies to cut
it back to two maybe one but for one
shining moment we had call ante circuses
Joyce betrayal of a guy who doesn't have
to wear a mocap suit and kill mugger
Michael B Jordans Michael Jordan of
Marvel villains Nancy he's the buffest
dude to ever graduate from MIT who's
ribbed for your pleasure and who
actually wins a moral argument and
changes the hero's mind where was
Wakanda to turn your backs on the rest
of the world so a kill mugger was right
I am not used to this much nuance in my
Marvel villains quick make him choking
old lady so I know who to root for oh
there he is
while the boys are at play it's the
women of Black Panther who do all the
work like a coy a literal snatcher of
wigs
shuri expert in weaponized beans angela
bassett as herself and Nakia who after
all the debate between T'Challa and kill
monger was making the same case all
along and never got the credit for it
akanda is strong enough to help others
and protect ourselves at the same time
also she saved the royal family though
also she say the future of the black
panther Wow
I am not used to this much agency my
marvel of interest quick harrogate
rescued so I know who the heroes are
phew so enjoy this movie with great
acting mas right this one's a great
story great things and great cultural
significance that almost let you forget
the underdeveloped love stories when you
kill me my love the terrible CGI or the
big forgettable third act brouhaha in
other words it's a Marvel movie starring
the superhero formerly known as Prince
oh there's Wallis Lupita you're so fine
you're so fine you blow my mind Lupita
Lupita fear the Chevy head
Bilbo Watson token token white guys joke
the best Disney Princess wardog way of
the samurai buster bluth got out the
trains down in Africa and the Arsenio
Hall Show the eristic ad you know his
hearts in the right place but maybe
don't let Everett Ross keep any guys
with one arm in custody guys over to any
line from Infinity Ward that you haven't
said yet the only thing a fighter Thor
fears a sphere itself Thanos and
Darkseid are stepbrothers every beholder
thinks it as the epitome of the
her kind and the only thing it fears is
that it might be wrong No